okay hi everyone we are doing a design
review today for Wolfram Alpha
functionality and this is Wolfram Alpha
blockchain functionality
so
let's start off with
this query all right so that's clearly
wrong we don't capitalize units right
units are not usually capitalized
correct
umichi can you tell
well I can tell you I mean I can tell
you the units are not usually
capitalized
okay yeah okay change the whole thing
um
if I say something like this you'll see
every unit as stated without
capitalization
uh
no big deal I mean there's going to be
lots of these so I mean I'm just gonna
you know
go down this
I don't know where the main net should
be capitalized I mean I think Bitcoin
be capitalized let me see
do you understand my question sure
um
okay maybe yes it's not clear it's what
we use on the as an option on on the
language but our options are always
capitalized so it doesn't tell you
anything about this and that's
absolutely wrong right so don't do that
with capitals it's not what we do is
there somebody here who's used to doing
Wolfram Alpha design reviews
no but proof of work is usually written
that way that's why we use it proof of
work like this I I understand with
capital letters I don't think so yes yes
yes
um I don't think so is there anybody
here who's used to doing uh Johan you're
certainly used to doing we haven't done
so many of these recently but but um
right uh you're used to doing these but
is there somebody here Alan is here I'm
here has anybody well but I has I don't
know if this has gone through D.A for
for a pass over things like that
no but yeah no I don't think so but this
is a okay this is a good thing a very
specific thing so um the the people from
Blossom group are the most qualified for
reviewing this that's why we we we're
purposely good proof of working capitals
because that's usually how you how it's
used
as referred to
you know what it's not I'm looking at it
on the web and it's not
sorry
I mean it often gets abbreviated as cat
cat P lowercase o capital W but that
doesn't mean that when you spell it out
you
I don't know where the main net should
be capitalized possibly yes okay but
let's take a look at what what
information you have here
um
I don't understand why that says
blockchain there I mean
that's not how we usually do it
I mean if I say some kind of animal or
something like you know that that's not
how we usually would set it up right
why am I so out of practice with these
things
I mean you know that's what I mean not
to say it would be the name without a a
gray background
and then paren blockchain
right
am I making sense
is basically if what this is is
basically an entity scan then yes that's
what it would be
right
Okay so
assuming this is not right
okay it's much closer to this
am I making sense yeah and how would we
uh refer to if we're using the mainnet
here
I don't know double press I don't know
I mean I'm not sure what I I don't know
we have to look at this
does the main net need to be in the II I
mean is there another a different
network that Bitcoin is on I I don't
know enough about this space even too
that's a test nut
but but you asked her about Bitcoin
blockchain you didn't even refer to
mainnet it's good it's it's it should
have at the top assuming mainnet
do you understand what I'm saying yes
that's how it should work listen we got
a lot to go through so we're gonna have
to go quickly and I'm just going to tell
you stuff and I you know we're taking
notes okay right and hopefully this is
being recorded and then we'll have to
probably come back on this again okay
um now that blocks there is that unit a
standard unit or is that some other is
that some special unit for blockchain
it's a custom unit for blockchain well
you got it wrong then
because look what just happened when I
clicked it
okay okay
you got it wrong so we probably have to
define a new unit that is a blockchain
block get what I'm saying
um
okay
is that the right term for proof of work
a consensus mechanism
it's not really like work I mean it's
it's not really that's not the consensus
that's being determined by proof of work
it's the
there's a different term for it but you
see what I'm saying consensus is
I mean the consensus
as a complete idiot about this stuff if
you just
searching on online if there's lots of
references to proof of work as one of
two main consensus mechanisms for
validating Trends all right then then
people are calling it consensus
mechanism
okay
shouldn't that have a hyphen there
I don't know
I'm just asking can somebody tell me the
answer I mean somebody I would I would
say no but I'm not an expert in this
okay but this is what we have to go
through right and and this is what we're
this is the point here okay
okay that's nice to have it in US
dollars
but but this parenthesization
that minimum fee is dynamic right so
that minimum fee is for April 24th
correct
yes so so it's incorrect to put the put
the April 24th in parentheses along with
the dollars as if this is a fixed number
but this is floating based on exchange
rate am I making sense
yes right so what we need to do is this
thing here paren or you know whatever
dollars and then separately parenthesis
April 24
2023 I'm not making sense
yes right
now is this really result or summary
it's not really the result is it
I would suggest that that should be
called summary okay you're probably
you're probably getting result because
of how this parse has been set up right
like if this was being treated as just a
pure entity parse then it would that pod
would have a different name but because
this is looks like you've got it set it
up as an entity property thing
it's coming back as a result
I think you're right it would make more
sense for this to be
just uh just an entity parse and then
that pod it says it has a different
title
okay
why are we giving a date here why aren't
we just saying today or something
is that how we normally do this Alan
others to indicate that it's current
sorry it depends I mean what I don't I
don't know where well I mean this the
value the value the values for Bitcoin
so is it but is it
is it today or is where when is what is
the actual data right now it's right now
okay
why does that say April 21st
because that's end of day and today's a
Monday
okay
that's why I'm not sure about the
Bitcoin value I don't know if they're by
the way we should annotate this is end
of day right here
separate topic okay
um this is presumably I mean this is up
to the minute yes
well yes
so don't just say April 24th because it
isn't April 24th it's now it's Miranda
the the April 24th uh makes uh reference
to the the exchange rate not the the
minimum fee I'm well aware of that
okay
well actually I I wasn't aware of that
both of these are floating right both of
these change
the minimum fee is for the most recent
block is that correct
yes that's right okay so and the
exchange rate is for what time
for the latest we have available in in
our saying which is when roughly I mean
minutes one block ago
um
don't we have the the currency
conversion at the granularity
I believe so
that's why it's ever 24 because we get
the that cut off at dates
okay so so guys
we gotta do this more carefully okay so
this is lost block
so we should probably say
something like latest minimum fee
do you understand what I'm saying
latest block latest minimum fee
um
I would say I know that height is a
common term here but I would say
what I would do is to say total blocks
and then here to say since
Inception
okay did you understand what I'm saying
yes but I believe that's confusing
why because everyone says height
uses height I mean all right well then
then I I don't know it seems wrong to me
but but I'm well aware that I've already
used his height
okay we can say that but then say that
number of blocks paren since Inception
am I making sense
okay
I mean that will make it a little bit
clear to somebody who's not an expert
what the heck this might mean
that's why we added the definitions
there also
I don't look at that
and I can't look at that apparently
they're not showing up
does that surprise you that they're not
showing up
uh yes it should be showing up probably
because it was
loaded it's it's been a while since the
the page loaded
that does not seem like a valid excuse
to me but well try it out
okay did Carla did you chase whatever
was happening with current
I checked with uh Lexi and it seems like
maybe someone was doing a merch but
um she's aware of that what's happening
and they have stopped that
well we got a problem here don't we
do I need to get hold of these Folk
let me check with her again
make sure Lexi has because I don't think
I don't think Lexi is going to be the
person who knows about this
okay
okay I would I would never suggest it's
your network but I'm I'm running the
same query and other ones and it's
coming up quickly for me
I know I'm not I know it can be all
kinds of things but
one other date one other data point it's
working it's working very
speedily for me and definitions are
showing up on current
well it won't be Network it might be an
incorrect routing yeah I don't know
oh there we go
I don't know offhand if we usually
capitalize the words the words and
definitions I don't think would look
good I suspect we don't
per KB
really
it's not right per kilobyte I don't
think it was per kilobyte
guys
this is using a an internal function
from the 8.0 that no no no I'm I'm
asking what is the minimum fee the
minimum fee on bitcoin
does it depend on how much data you have
in the block
in the transaction yes
okay well KB isn't correctly spelled
because it shouldn't look like that it
should it should say why don't you just
spell out per kilobyte
and don't say in satoshi's because not
we already give the unit here you don't
have to say in satoshi's here
do you understand what I'm saying yeah
also you can't have a capital letter
there you can't start a new sentence
there
do you understand what I'm saying yeah
okay I'm gonna just give you these
things we've got a zillion things to go
over I cannot you've got to respond so
that I know you understand yes yes no
don't worry I got it
uh this doesn't seem right this really
this wording does not seem right you
should go over this with a D.A Folk
okay
okay head words and definitions are not
capitalized answers
okay you need to make sure you get a
meeting with the da folk to go over this
okay which probably which should have
happened before the meeting with me
okay
and the jobs that are picking up uh
currency
conversions are typically it's an re job
it's running every day at noon I believe
so those are those are as of
noon Central let's check on the time
zone but if it's of the midday so for
for this particular thing
this seems troubled
to
you know this is a very volatile
you know cryptocurrencies are a very
volatile thing it really doesn't seem it
seems like we need to find a way to get
more more up to the minute conversions
which I think we should be able to do
independent of our
uh right so that's why I I didn't I
wasn't sure if this the whole other
thing that's being called to get the
blockchain information had its own
pipeline for prices it sounds like
that's not the case so we should talk
about having merged in with it right
yeah we need to do that
okay
um
all right let's keep going I mean there
may be some things here
that will want to talk about further
ethereum
should I not even try on that
um
why is that in small font when the other
one is in larger font
um that was done to specify that this is
a hashtag and it goes to a different oh
that with a hash uh string no no look
this is the set this is not smaller font
is it
yes it is well it is it is a smartphone
okay all right fine
I see
and the reason I mean that's all zero is
because it's a proof of work blockchain
makes sense
how many characters are there in the
whole hash
how long is the whole hash
I think
the things before yeah yeah
how many
64 I believe
64 characters characters yeah 32 bites
so particularly for Bitcoin it's quite
interesting to see the whole thing
because you can see all the zeros
oh I see there's the full thing there's
a mouse over
and what happens if I click that
is that really do we write PM like that
you didn't custom do this did you you're
using some standard date formatting yes
yes
what version of what
version of what
this is coming straight from the note
this uh version by a version number
that's given us for each block I believe
do you have any idea what the factory is
because we're not just going to say
version and not know what it is
can you check on the definitions
what does that mean
and don't just say confirmations number
of confirmations
just you know say something that's more
useful than just restating
the and byte count
size of block and it's not byte count
because
well maybe that one's okay what what
would you say instead of um in
confirmations because that's usually
what we we have seen in other
definitions no no
is
it's no good to just say confirmations
number of confirmations
okay
okay what is version of the block
yeah so it is a number that indicates
which set of block validation rules are
being followed it will be updated as
Tangles on different blocks
I don't understand that
I don't understand explain that again so
if if I look at the next block on the
blockchain will it have the same version
number typically or not not sure how
how fast they change
let me see
well
no this isn't right this isn't right
this is some
um
and I don't know why we're not giving
more detailed stuff about the block oh
we are by the way Merkel is presumably
you know Ralph is presumably a person
who has a capital letter name unless
he's been decapitalized
um
I mean what is this root isn't that a
block of a particular
what is that is that
that's not a block that's just a no yeah
right yes
of each transaction in a block enjoy
okay
I think it would be nice
in um
for the Bitcoin blockchain at least to
put in paren here
leading zeros
do you understand what I'm saying no
makes sense yes uh however we had an
issue when we tried to do the formatting
for the latest block because we would go
right over into the next line if we keep
the zeros or we keep the hushes did you
listen to what I said I I suggest I'm
just saying
you know whatever it is now 14 zeros
okay
we can address that
yes
oh my God this guy on here I mean I hope
this is not an intrinsically slow
operation
oh it's not it's because we're in
current and current is slow
you know it's going to be really hard to
do this even this
even then they should be they shouldn't
be successful
okay can somebody reach out to
um Roger and ask him if there's any
reason why I can't imagine it I mean
unless it's a routing problem I cannot
imagine a suit here it's working fine
for me okay well let's let's reach out
to Roger what's that I'll do that yeah
and let him know what's going on
okay
yeah obviously fix the capitalization
here
yeah
timed out
okay is it capital b or lowercase B
please decide
do you see what I'm saying yeah yeah
right should we lower case
should it
I think so yes as far as I remember well
the use lowercase
okay well what does ethereum use
what's a what sorry what does ethereum
use
oh
yeah you've got to check it right yeah
yeah let's move on okay why is there no
plot here
looks very units don't have a
value value yeah
[Music]
that's not a traded cryptocurrency no
okay
um
I'm wondering if there's a better way to
state
it's probably okay though
all right
Arc
okay wait a minute Explorer URL why is
that not present on other ones
Evolution handles its own Explorer again
an official room
right so so we don't want we don't we
don't have the same thing in every
blockchain because it's hard to try to
get some standard for everything these
all work different
we're trying to standardize as best as
we could yeah okay is there a core for
Arc
um
I think there isn't in the case we're
using blocks really custom
yes
what on Earth does constants mean
what does that mean
um
you guys have got to get you right I
mean we've we've we have we've got to be
able to in a review like this you have
got to be able to answer what these
things mean
do you remember about this
Constance
ah yes I believe there are uh some
volumes that are constant in yes I
realize that I can tell in this Epoch
yes I understand that point
that that's not a good way to I mean
what has lost revised in what does that
mean what does that mean
s what it means yes but what block
number are we at right now
we're at block number
23.72 million yes
okay so this is a block presumably yes
it is
Okay so we've got to indicate that
somehow otherwise it's last revised in
and somebody thinks it's a date
blocks ago
whatever that would be fine okay okay
I mean it would be nice to indicate that
this is a last revised on at a certain
block
okay I mean it thus revised at
hmm
and the epoch here
I these seem like they're different
right
I don't know what that is that was last
revised in April this was last revised
this Epoch presumably refers to that
block there am I making sense
I'm not sure I believe this Epoch is the
creation of the
whole blockchain
let me check
okay now that April is still refers to
the conversion not not the the date it
was uh but why do we have a conversion
from April 30 oh because you because
you took the screenshot then yes
okay
Jessie book is the Genesis block a
timestamp
okay well if we're giving a Genesis
block timestamp we could do that for
Bitcoin as well which will be kind of
interesting
do you understand what I'm saying
yeah
I don't call leapock I mean just call it
something like
um
start time or something I don't know
something like that I mean but we
definitely want to see that for all the
blockchains and we should show that up
at the top it's relevant in the whole
shebang of what is the story of bloxburg
oh it's
whatever it is oh that was Arc I mean
bloxburg it's like it's X years old you
see what I'm saying
yes
that's a really useful thing to have
okay Max payload seems like it should
have units
am I making sense
why would it not have units
okay
come on guys
what is this it looks nice but what is
it
oh there are different kinds of
transactions and each transaction has
its own fees and this is a way to
represent it in one single child what
would the it is this is this is like a
box whisker chart is that right
what is this what is this picture of
maximum and minimum fees of each
transaction okay thank you and what's
the what's that Mark
average yeah okay so it's a it's like a
box whisker chart
but we've got to indicate I mean
okay and what units is this in
okay
so Market
here Mark that on the axis
what period of time is this averaged
over
this is airport entire Epoch and the
revision of these rules that are set
here
wait a minute you've said two different
things
Epoch you said here means the Genesis
block Epoch this is not the Genesis
block so which is it uh the last revised
from the last revise these values are
the ones are staying but that means that
that's over a very very very long period
of time
which doesn't seem like it's the right
thing to be plotting
you see what I'm saying like for Bitcoin
for example the the price of a
transaction will have gone from
practically nothing to some quite large
value when Bitcoin was flying high
do you understand what I'm saying it's
not very useful to show these results
across you know that whatever it is how
long is it 15 years 20 years whatever it
is the bitcoin's been around
do you understand what I'm saying
yes yes
so I I think this is a lovely picture
but it needs to be understood to be over
a shorter period And I would have
thought that the right thing to do would
be over the past you know day
or something I think uh based on what
the information that I got that we got
from the arc
from the backlit this data is pretty
much standardized I mean this uh the the
minimum the maximum limits for this type
of transactions are constant say like
for in this case
they are
they haven't changed in so much
um
just to uh
bring
um yes this is static fees there are up
top those are like the ones are worse
um fixed and then they change they
change to Dynamic fees uh later these
are like uh the previous version but
also suggested I believe then they
changed and I'm not sure if this
Statistics are
because this seems like it's nonsense
right they're either using Dynamic fees
in this revision number
or they're not if they're using static
fees only in prior to block 1.7 million
this whole bat panel is kind of stupid
do you understand what I'm saying
okay
right it shouldn't be that because it's
totally confusing
right
it would only be there if you asked for
a block that was that was old because
most of the time if you say hey is this
a blockchain that has big transaction
fees knowing what they were you know
five years ago is not really very
relevant
do you understand what I'm saying
yes
um
and I you know just calling this block
oh I see this is all under constants
I mean I would call it something like
blockchain parameters or some such other
thing
yeah it could be we're I mean
we try to use their own names because
it's
if people of the United States I
understand but we have to take you know
we have to compromise between
incomprehensibility
it's not easy
okay each blockchain
the design analysis people at all
oh no no
right so that's that would be a really
good thing to do
um
okay let's go on taking a look here
I can't believe ID is lowercase
maybe it is but I wouldn't have thought
so
um
by the way up here
there's the X no maybe not I'm sorry I
took over extra space is better than not
no boy
wow
these really are different zoo animals
aren't they exactly yes and we've tried
to clean it up as much as we could and
let's turn around as much as we could
but
yeah and we're not even sure if we
should include that much information
because it's
it's confusing
well
but maybe for the people that use this
blockchain would be a good idea yeah I
think and it's also interesting honestly
just to see that there are you know
animals with different feeding habits so
to speak I mean it you know they're
really different
I'm actually surprised you know I know a
decent amount about these things and I'm
surprised how many things here aren't
you know standardized
just to you know just to try to
standardize a Visa result but it took a
while because okay what should we
include that that part of this should be
standardized right so well but it isn't
because the slot number is not yeah the
last the last tuna but yeah it's it's
kind of tricky
how can the well I don't
know latest epoch
so number is the epoch number is that
correct
yes
okay
no this is just not right what you've
done is just not right
I mean it should be
I think
there's two different concepts here
there's a blockchain like Bitcoin and
there's a blockchain network like the
Bitcoin mainnet
am I not right
yes
so I'm kind of thinking that what we
should do
is to say Bitcoin okay in in the case of
in the first case here
oh boy the whole thing is only for
mainnet because the the characteristics
of Bitcoin you know the fact that it is
utxo based and so on
um
there's a there's a constant fact about
um Bitcoin independent of the fact that
this is about mainnet
am I making sense yeah that's correct
but everything else here is about the
mainnet
though in though in theory you could
have
I believe uh
mainnet in utxo and you know a test net
in
if you're testing something new I
believe
I'm not sure how ethereum did it when
they you know
uh switch to yeah when they switched
over to proof of stake right
um
I mean it seems to me that that first
line should say blockchain type
not name
blockchain type and then the SEC second
one
is basically blockchain what the
blockchain is and the answer is it's
Bitcoin mainnet
oh
this is I mean I don't know all of them
maintenance that are part of the same
thing
aren't all of them part of Bitcoin
alternatively
I mean if I went to the test net how how
many I mean the minimum fee on the test
net I don't understand even how the test
net works the test net has a whole bunch
of blocks on it how many blocks does it
have on it
right now I don't know let me check
how big is it relative to bitcoin itself
um we'll leave this about 2.4 million
so the test net is bigger than the
actual
okay so I can ask for Bitcoin test net
right
is that correct
yes yes
and I assume you've got some good
Linguistics around that
okay it don't think it should be in
parenze I think it should be Bitcoin I
mean first of all it should have a great
background that's just at least not for
the non-property case
um it should just say
I think I would suggest saying Bitcoin
and then just mainnet in Gray
and then say paren
either blockchain or blockchain Network
do you see what I'm saying
yes we are already figuring out how to
Showcase it
okay right because if we set Bitcoin
test net then uh we'll be better to say
blockchain Network to be more expensive
right yeah yeah and param blockchain
Network
um
and it's good
so it might be nice
ah why do you even say cryptocurrency
for the test net
because not an exchangeable
cryptocurrency on the test net
how do you indicate that the test net
do you understand what I'm saying
well we are in uh showing the exchange
history nor the conversion fee and the
minimum fee I understand that but that's
well you're showing a minimum fee there
you've got a signal I don't I don't
really know how the test net Works can
you put what can you put on the test net
it's basically a copy of the minute
um for you to test new transactions
you can exchange in those so why are
people using test the test net to
actually do transactions with each other
they can but the money has uh it doesn't
have an exchange rate a value yeah
nobody's hooked up and exchanged the
test Network the blocks are much easier
to to mine to get mined
yeah okay yes
okay but we should indicate here when we
say cryptocurrency that's a little bit
misleading for the test net is it not
but that's like other networks that
don't have any exchange so maybe we
should have a property saying yeah
exchangeable or something like that I
think that would be right
um
that's what I would do
now
you know this isn't great if you say
Bitcoin height
you should say this number of blocks
and then you know there's all kinds of
stuff we can do like we can show the
blocks as a function of Time how many
blocks there were as a function of time
we can plot all kinds of interesting
things here
but at the very least we should say
since when is it that many blocks
see what I'm saying before we fall into
the basic information part which is no
longer called results here
do you understand what I'm saying
okay
what's this going to do
oh gosh
come on guys we can do this right
and
[Music]
um
why not because in this case it's making
a call to the blockchain packlet and the
blockchain packet has a static info has
just uh current information for every
blockchain Network
we don't have historicals in that
let's go with the data
well but we certainly do on I mean I
thought we had gone to a lot of trouble
to be able to do that
I mean if I go and I say oh this doesn't
seem right to me
if if I would say
um
that's going to be a block right
yes because in this case you are
querying Bitcoin tested you're not
querying for a block in particular
so I and I'll I'm not sure
or block data
no you're saying you're saying for the
you're saying it maybe it was to do with
the test net
because this is a perfectly good
you know yeah but you're requiring for a
particular block there in this case
slightly more
I'm asking you have a table for that
for what
for the state of Bitcoin blockchain on a
certain date
well yeah it's a certain block number
right it's right here
we can convert the Vlog and relate the
Vlog to its date time yeah right that's
what I'm suggesting yes that look up
going to be uh fast enough in this case
of those things yeah just uh okay
we can do that yes
yeah I mean things like this should work
and and um you know I hope we could
answer questions like you know when was
Bitcoin first worth a thousand dollars
yeah
can we
yeah see we can yeah okay
um
is there any useful plot that we can
make of the
of the transaction Network
no
given a particular block
um
there are things like the minor IDs that
are in in that block the things written
into the block right
right yes okay
and we should expose those
Governor we're asking about a particular
block presumably we're going to expose
I'm about to see I don't know presumably
we're going to expose what instructions
were in that block
I guess the instructions are per
transaction
wait a minute where does it say
s okay but but wait a minute there are
different I mean the the Bitcoin
protocol
has a whole variety of instructions you
can run
for a given transaction correct
yes you mean the script right yes the
script
where are we showing the decoding of the
script here
we are not showing them
in this case no we aren't but we have
the script right
um
it'd be nice to show some basic decoding
of it
don't you think well at utterly level
I'm not sure if we are doing in this
case the decoding when you do it uh on
the blockchain packet is it using
Mathematica 13.
because I I recall that there was a
version conflict
regarding the version okay okay okay so
if there's something you can't do yeah
you'll be able to do soon yeah and we'll
treat those I mean let's check that but
um
how good is the Linguistics on all of
this stuff
have you done significant work on that
yeah
it's it's has it gone to lextov yet or
have you guys just done placeholder
stuff
we were working with uh the Linguistics
team but mainly for the blockchain and
blogspot
since that's more
independent from using hashes on the on
the query
yeah okay
yes
now I mean other other visualizations
and things that we can readily produce
here
um that's one thing we have been trying
to think about but
we haven't come up with anything
other than the exchange rates and what
you saw about the transactions and well
I mean just trivially like Christopher
has these things about things like this
number of unique miners per thousand
blocks and so on
um
so this is not the only property that
can be computed but that is an example
of one
where we include that
what sort of questions well I don't know
I think I think that that would be a
um you know that's a useful thing
to have I mean for example
um
if we had any way of of getting a proxy
for how many nodes there were running at
a given time that will be useful
for each blockchain in other words is
this just
so and so and his dog
or is it 10 000 nodes around the world
yeah that's useful I'm not sure how to
check if that's possible I don't know
either I mean we get information from
our Arnold I don't know if or if our
node knows how many nodes are active
yeah I don't know I don't know yeah
maybe we can check interesting I mean
that confirmations is giving you some
measure of that
yeah
no confirmations is just no yes
transactions
the number of blocks it is behind the
current hit
ah yes so we should clarify what that
means I mean when you just said number
of confirmations that's absolutely
useless in the definitions
so
confirmations means that
wait a second that this transaction
is that far from the latest transaction
received by the thing that is reporting
on the latest transaction so to speak
but what was the confirmations in the
original
this doesn't seem right
this is a block per block basis
sorry where
so you're saying the confirmations only
shot start showing up at the Block Level
yes we're um okay and if I was to look
at the head block
which may not even be in the system yet
it would say
that's right
okay
all right I should probably wrap up
this is looking really I mean you know
apart from the fact there are all these
little details this is looking like a
you know this is looking nice there's
good stuff finally we've been talking
about this for how many years
I don't know but any case
um
do a password design analysis
as far as I'm concerned this could go up
once you've done that although I'd like
to see it again and try and comment on
some more things
okay does that sound reasonable
Alan do you want to comments on anything
here
no I think other than other than little
details I think we're good here
right and um
I mean a typical thing somebody's going
to want to do
is
I mean
you know what level okay given an
address can I look it up
yes
okay
I think there are some examples of that
right ug yes
okay given an nft can I look it up yeah
sure
where do I have examples of that here
we can we can uh look for tokens I know
tokens sorry sources yes not nfts yeah
nice
that's nice
when you say wait
um oh my God I have I've it's been so
long since I thought about nfts I've
forgotten the name of the ERC
okay thank you
um
so for example here
why are these not sorted by I don't
understand
I mean they should be sorted down by a
number of holders presumably
yeah I mean what ordering is this
the ordering the hashes what the heck is
the ordering here uh it's ordered us the
node it gives the tokens it's not
ordered in any way from our side because
it's not we don't have access to all the
tokens we I believe we we can only call
to up to a thousand tokens and ordering
those will be like misleading because
it's not actually the order
we know the most popular tokens right
yes right
so we can order them starting from the
most popular tokens
yes okay
um
okay
well that doesn't look very promising
with that whole account of one or two
um
nfts
have
an address
he does
am I correct that's right Jess
so you should be able to type in the
address and get information about it
that's right but but right now
what's important is what the standard is
which determines the script
is that right uh yeah the behavior of
the token yes
okay but if I just throw you a random
nft
you know address
what can you do with it
uh
uh that's a good question because we are
relating the address with uh protocol uh
if the talking is
foreign
this animation for that yeah okay fine
but then given another address on a
particular blockchain of an nft you can
look up stuff about that nft can you not
yes I can yeah but does that work
already
yes
okay and it's going through the pathway
here that says look up an address
yes of course that's right yes but does
it know that that address corresponds to
an nft
that's right yes
it is more like a general data about
somebody okay so I'm asking does it know
that it corresponds to nft because
by looking at scripts it can know that
it isn't erc721 token it can it not
we can
no
if this particular address is an erc20
or erc21 721 sorry yeah yeah
you can know that yes yes
okay all right we should wrap up here
but I I'm saying you should expose that
because you're not exposing that right
here
you're not saying what this address
actually corresponds to is it um I mean
you should identify that
okay yeah
um all right nice stuff I'm gonna depart
uh
any any further questions here
oh okay see you guys soon
okay bye bye for now